hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my x-men trailer breakdown from
comic-con
just like the the Deadpool stuff Fox is
taking down all the leaks hardcore
someone it to get a little creative with
the way I showed footage the really big
takeaways are that we actually got to
see what Oscar Isaac looks like in
full-on apocalypse makeup full-on final
boss form apocalypse if you guys read
x-men access that that comic happened a
little I think it was last year maybe
the year before that they have the
'event character who's like a child like
apocalypse he's actually a clone turned
into full-blown apocalypse this is
actually kind of what he looks like in
the current comics everybody has their
favorite version of the character he
looks a little bit different in the
Ultimate Comics you know all across the
80s and the 90s one of if not the best
comic book story that he had is Age of
Apocalypse the classic version they've
reimagined that paradigm a couple
different times in the comics so like
there's the canoer Age of Apocalypse
just read the classic one first this is
just the concept art but it looks like
pretty close to what this is is I think
it's about as realistic as they could
get without getting like too crazy
the problem with apocalypse in the
comics when you start dealing with film
stuff is that he is kind of a ridiculous
character he's meant to be like that fan
O's level villain and imagine what would
have happened if Thanos had shown up say
in like that first Iron Man film before
they done some of the crazier stuff
comic book people would have loved it
but like the rest the world would have
been like what the hell is this I feel
like 50% of people will give him a
thumbs down 50% will give them a thumbs
up Oscar Isaac is great at playing like
really weird characters so I actually I
think the performance will be great
there really isn't enough of him in this
trailer to make make a good judgement so
I'm withholding like a longer analysis
of Oscar Isaacs performance til we get a
full blown trailer but the other big
stars of this trailer are new characters
like the recast younger x-men and the
new characters like Psylocke sophie
Turner is the new Jean Grey I don't feel
like a lot of her Game of Thrones scenes
do her justice so I feel like this film
will give you a better sense for her
ability as an actor there's new
Nightcrawler new storm I'm totally
digging the storm look new Cyclops and
Moira MacTaggert at the comic-con panel
Channing Tatum and Ryan Reynolds joined
them on stage so we could see some
Deadpool and gambit in this movie but
but they're not
to be big parts of it I don't know about
you guys but I am really happy that
Fox's Italy at least embracing the idea
of superhero movie crossovers everybody
uses Marvel as the benchmark just
because they got there first but you
know I feel like Fox has a real
opportunity with all of its IP who else
wants to see a starjammers movie I feel
like that would be Fox's guardians of
the galaxy so the trailer opens up on a
shot of cerebro and then we get this
Jean Grey scene with sophie turner she
shoots up in bed and says that she saw
the end of the world she has she has
this nightmare about everything going to
then we're flying over an old city with
an apocalypse voice over saying I've
been called many things over many
lifetimes raah Krishna Yahweh Moira
MacTaggert says ever since the world
found out about mutants there have been
secret societies Colts who see them as
some kind of second coming or a sign of
God then apocalypse walks into a room
with a hood on saying I was there to
spark and fan the flame of man's
awakening to spin the wheel of
civilization so he's just explaining how
he's functionally immortal and he's been
around for almost everything that the
human race is seen then it jumps back to
my rent she says I was tracking one of
them they believe that tens of thousands
of years ago an ancient being was born
the world's first and then you know cuts
to James MacAvoy saying mutant so it's
pretty clear that a lot of this film is
especially the early part of the film is
gonna be dedicated to apocalypses origin
story which I actually think is pretty
cool
then it cuts to a shot of Jennifer
Lawrence and beast looking really
worried then it cuts to another shot of
apocalypse like it the camera is slowly
moving up his breastplate it lands right
on the a and then he says you were all
my children and you're lost because you
follow the wrong leader everything they
built will fall and from the ashes of
their world will build a better one so
they're teasing Age of Apocalypse that's
basically what the movie is the lead-up
to what that was in the comics although
Age of Apocalypse in the comics was like
an alternate far future timeline and
this is taking place in the 80s then it
cuts to shots of Magneto
Nightcrawler and storm standing next to
apocalypse like an in with her full-on
80s mohawk then it cuts to another shot
of magneto turning to someone off camera
reacting to someone saying who the F are
you and then BOOM like full-on
apocalypse shot with his armor on
my best approximation is that this
version of apocalypse looks closest to
the 80s designs like the original
apocalypse then we just cut to a bunch
of different shots to some of the other
x-men some of the supporting characters
like Cyclops Psylocke and Quicksilver
then Jennifer Lawrence says mutants are
being hunted living in fear
Xavier puts his cerebro head on and he
says I've never felt power like this
before
the double meaning being the power that
Sabri bro gives him and the power that
he feels coming off of apocalypse so
just to be clear Channing Tatum and Ryan
Reynolds did not appear in the trailer
and if they do appear in the movie at
all it's probably gonna be like very
very small cameos but they were on stage
with them at Comic Con so everybody
cross your fingers for them being in the
movie either way I think it's gonna be
really interesting this movie I feel is
more important to the x-men film
franchise than Days of Future past Days
of Future past was a fun movie but this
is bringing in a ton of recast new
characters if audiences really buy into
all these new people that they're
bringing in then then they're fine
they'll be great
like imagine Marvel bringing in a bunch
of new characters to the Avengers and
people hating him it would destroy all
those future Avengers films even if you
didn't get a chance to see the trailer
let me know what do you think about this
movie so far but you know based on what
you've heard or what you've seen
like I said Fox hasn't really said when
they're gonna post an official version
of the trailer Ryan Reynolds did say
that Deadpool is coming in about three
weeks so hopefully Fox will also release
x-men footage around that time typically
like October November is when really big
trailers come like like if you remember
back to last year November is when that
first Star Wars Episode 7 trailer
dropped a lot of you guys have been
asking for trailers for Star Wars and in
some of the other stuff at Comic Con I'm
working my way down the list I think I'm
actually gonna do Star Wars next and
then I'm gonna do arrow season 4 after I
get through all that stuff I'm gonna
start doing character videos so if
there's any characters that they
announced the comic-con that you guys
really want me to do videos for first
just let me know in the comments and be
sure to subscribe to get everything I'm
gonna start closing mike-mike giveaways
from Comic Con in the next couple of
days if you're not sure about those all
you have to do is just like leave a
comment on one of my Comic Con videos
they're separate giveaways for Marvel DC
Doctor Who you know like all the
different fandoms so justjust leave a
comment on one of those videos and
you're good to go well guys wait for all
that stuff to post you can click here to
watch my Deadpool trailer breakdown
again and you can click here to watch my
suicide
Squad trailer breakdown thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you